the refugee crisis in ukraine getting
worse there's unimaginable suffering
happening right now as russia pummels
residential areas the un says 1.2
million ukrainians have fled the country
and another 800 000 have been displaced
that includes over a half million
children
as you know my mother-in-law is one of
the lucky ones she just made her escape
from ukraine arriving in poland
yesterday reuniting with her daughter my
wife elena
uh i have to warn you though this video
has been known to cause a run on tissues
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
oh
thank you so much
thank you so much
what was it like waiting
i'm sorry what was it like waiting oh my
god it was awful it was absolutely awful
but i'm so happy to have her
yes
[Music]
turn it off she says that was harrigan
it's amazing they were still wearing
their masks yeah if you drive across a
war-torn country for two days i think
you could probably take off your mask
but this was possible thanks to my
incredible colleagues here at fox steve
harrigan who you heard there
interviewing my wife trey yingston scott
wilder so she was fortunate enough to
make it to safety but there are still
millions in danger
we don't know what to do that's why we
cross
to
another country my colleague was shot by
russian soldiers in when she tried to go
out of kiev to jatomir and and she was
shot she's dead now i'm a mother i just
want to protect my son i'm feeling a lot
of pain a lot of pain for my country and
my people who did you leave behind
oh but in the face of evil there's still
good in the world and heroes everywhere
like the people on the ground risking
their own lives to lead others to safety
and others who are doing what they can
to help out charities like project
dynamo uh it's rescuing people in the
middle of this fighting and getting them
out of the country private companies are
also stepping up for example uber is
offering free rides between the poland
and ukraine border although jesse they
won't drive you because of your one star
rating
i've been tipping oh that's good that's
good i think i've done my job
i think i've done my job who are you
going to rescue
myself yes
wow greg that was great we used a fox
news alert for that i didn't i didn't
think that was possible yes um but that
was a great video and and we're all
really happy for you and your entire
family and
i think you should um
throw a party for everybody when they
get back to the united states
and um
and you know listen i i want to make a
joke but i don't think it's appropriate
so i won't but it was great to see that
and great to see your wife so happy you
know she's not always a happy person
i'm glad you could finally make her
happy no that is so you know that's
closer to the truth than you might
expect so you know but judge i feel
guilty i mean i feel guilty because
that's just one person right i mean we
know that there are people with their
grandmothers and what can they do and
what should how do they what do they do
i mean project dynamo is one
one group i was in contact with but they
were and they had gone to afghanistan
before and gotten people out there are
so many organizations i mean whether
it's project dynamo or even bethany
frankel has an organization look people
want to help people are essentially good
and charitable but you shouldn't feel
guilty at all i mean the truth is that
you were able to help in in one way but
i think that this is an example of the
hard choices that people are making
every one of those people that we've
seen has been separated from a loved one
the women from their husbands or their
brothers or their fathers you know and
and the men from their children and
their wives and it is it is so
devastating to think that this thug in
russia is doing nothing but destroying
the lives of innocent people who have
done nothing
and you know whether it's people going
there with meals like this chef andres
or or you know just sending money to
non-government organizations to do good
things i mean we bleed for people and i
think that the more this goes on and as
macron said the worse it's going to get
i think the more americans are going to
start to say you know let's do something
we've got to do something but where are
these people going we've got a million
point two refugees going all over europe
now where's the u.n are they setting up
are they taking care of these people
what housing do we have what about the
orphanages you know where are these kids
going what do you think martha
i i think it's an extraordinary story
your mother-in-law was in ukraine and
had she come from russia or was she
living in ukraine sure you know her uh
her husband passed away from covid uh
like last year so she'd been spending
time and she's born in ukraine she's a
ukrainian russian so she was with her
her cousins or whatnot in this little
tiny village when all of this stuff
happened so uh and then we had so we had
to get her out of there and get her back
you know and thanks to fox i mean you
know
well it really makes you
you know going through what you've gone
through it makes you so sympathetic to
what all of these people are going
through and that one woman who starts to
cry at the end of that video that we
just played i'm pretty sure that she
said after that that she had left her
husband
um when they said what did you leave
behind um because
the husbands are not allowed to leave if
they're age 18 to 60 right so they're
all staying behind to fight and the more
we learn about how long this could go on
i asked john kirby what this what the
pentagon thinks and he said
you know weeks or months but i think
that may be overly optimistic i think
this is potentially years
um in terms of an insurgency and how
long this could go on those fathers
could be separated from their children
for years potentially right yeah and
think about also you know there are
people in russia
these are their relatives too and so i
mean there are people in russia who have
loved ones that they're not going to see
anymore absolutely because they're going
to bifurcate that no one's going to be
able to cross and all because putin said
they were one one country yeah and these
guys right he's like we're all you're
all russian this is all ukraine's part
of russia so we should all be together
as if he was doing some altruistic
things yeah to bring the country back
together for his ego maniacal dream of a
russian empire that they don't want yeah
and i mean women are saying goodbye to
their husbands possibly forever i mean
they may never be reunited if they're
killed
in this war that they're fighting but
you know thank god for fox they during
the afghanistan withdrawal they were
helping to get interpreters and people
who the state department and the federal
government left behind out of there as
much as they could
great that they were able to able to
help with this situation as well you
know ukraine is a country of 44 million
people there's already 1.2 million who
have crossed the border into poland
poland has also been an amazing neighbor
in all of this they have welcomed them
with open arms and there are a number of
international but also u.s organizations
that are providing food and humanitarian
aid and that's just going to get worse
because a week ago people were saying in
kiev and all these other cities that
they had three days worth of food and
they may be in an orphanage where there
are dozens of hundreds of kids who need
to be fed well we're a week out from
that and when society breaks down very
quickly and people can't get basic
things like food and water so this
humanitarian these humanitarian paths
that they're trying to
make up with the russians putin hasn't
shown that he's actually doing that we
heard that there was some kind of
agreement but we haven't seen really any
movement on setting up that that flow of
humanitarian aid so we'll just have to
see um what happens but it's amazing
always how quickly things change uh you
know people having to leave and make the
decision overnight whether to leave
their families my husband was telling me
a story today about their organization
who's helping to get people out as well
and a man who's 59 years old came to the
border with six kids and dropped them
all off and had to go back
and so
you know there's
millions of these same kind of stories
yeah yeah well i'm very very lucky to be
working here that's for sure hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else